hey david let's talk about white
privilege do poor white
people have the same privilege
as rich white people i'm going to answer
the question
it's not a hugely relevant one because
the question of
privilege is better suited for
if you want to look at racial privilege
you need to really look at it where as
many other variables as possible are
held equal
so that you're really just looking at
the variable of race
so the question of whether a rich white
person has more
or less privilege than a poor white
person
is a fine question to ask the answer is
easy a poor
white per white person has far less
privilege than a rich white
person i mean there's a question that
that's your answer it's not
a very interesting question because it
doesn't really relate to the problems
we're trying to deal with in society
if everything other than skin color is
the same
then we can look at the specific effect
of skin color
as a factor and when you do that if you
imagine
a poor white person and a poor black
person if the only difference
is race then there is some degree
of white privilege that the poor white
person has
over the poor black person and in fact
there are some really interesting
studies with regard to employment
where they were for uh job out jobs were
open
low skilled jobs whatever i think some
were
housekeeping custodial type work other
low skilled jobs
and really big studies were done with
thousands of resumes with
identical skills names were different
traditionally white sounding names
versus traditionally black
sounding names were sent out and the
response rates retract
and sometimes the white sounding name
with the
same credentials as the black sounding
name
would get as much as a 50 percent higher
uh
call back or interview rate so that's an
example we're looking at low skilled
jobs you're not talking about wealthy
people or even upper middle class or
middle class people
and you see that there is a specific
difference
when varying only names that imply
a certain race okay that's interesting
to look at
poor white versus rich white of course
wealth confers
privilege and wealth confers advantage
now
i think it's also important to talk
about the reality that at a certain
level of wealth
wealth can start to override the lack of
privilege
that might come from some other factor
like race
or nationality or religion or gender or
whatever right there would be a certain
point at which one is so wealthy
that regardless of their race they are
going to
have a privilege in society that will
mostly make up for a characteristic
that would typically confer a
disadvantage
so the question is is a fine one
if you are sort of getting at the
privilege that wealth confers but from
the point of view of thinking about okay
poor white people and poor black people
might live in different neighborhoods
one of those neighborhoods
might be better connected with public
transit
that would be a form of privilege that
would relate
to race that would not necessarily be
obviously visible unless you really try
to fine-tune
and equate all but one variable isolate
one variable and try to figure out the
difference is there
that's my thought uh white privilege is
different
based on wealth but it's not a
particularly interesting question
since we know particularly in this
country wealth confers
a ton of privilege if i've misunderstood
your question
or you disagree with my answer by all
means
let me know we've got a great bonus show
planned for you today the bonus show is
for
members and patrons members and patrons
become a member at joinpacman.com or
become a patron
at patreon.com davidpakmanshow